Jamie Fox has been entertaining Millions
for decades but away from the spotlight
his family members have kept drifting
away this is the tragic true story of
the man born Eric Marlon Bishop Jamie
Fox's life was riddled with roadblocks
pretty much right from the start as he
was abandoned by both of his parents
when he was just a baby but it wasn't a
completely tragic origin story as he did
have other people in his life to look
after him as he recalled to O the Oprah
Magazine in 2005 my grandparents adopted
me when I was 7 months old I was never
short on the love of a mother and father
though it came from an earlier
generation of family the woman that fox
calls as grandmother Estelle Marie tally
is actually not his biological
grandmother but instead the adoptive
mother of his mother while his parents
left him behind he couldn't help but
miss them and hold out hope for them to
return as he recall my mom was so fly
and good-looking we were country but my
mom was straight City she had the new
hair the gold earrings the Stingray
Corvette however Fox had more mixed
feelings about his father as he put it
why couldn't he drive 28 mil to check on
a son who passed to football more than
1,000 yard I think some of his absence
has to do with his being a Muslim he
drew a line in the sand I'm a Muslim and
since you're not I can't be your father
Jamie Fox always had Ambitions to make
it big but his original goals were a
little different as the Texas bread
Entertainer hoped to one day play
professional football specifically he
wanted to be the quarterback for the
Dallas Cowboys and this was L to me a
pipe dream as he actually showed plenty
of promise on the field back in the day
while playing on the football squad at
Terell High School Fox became the first
quarterback to pass for more than 1,000
yards in the school's entire history
ultimately though Sports start him just
wasn't in the card as he wasn't blessed
with the right physical dimensions to
make it all the way to the pros
nevertheless Tero High made sure that
his athletic Legacy lived on and also
names their Performing Arts Center after
him tur baby while his football dreams
didn't work out Jamie Fox still had a
bright future ahead of him which was
clear when he attended the United States
International University in San Diego on
a music scholarship he was excited about
finally leaving behind the racial
bigotry of rural Texas and he hopes that
things would be different at College as
he recall to O the Oprah Magazine I'd
come from a world where blacks and
whites were separated by the town's
railroad tracks but at the University
there were people from 81 different
countries reality soon Came Crashing
Down on him though as Fox learned that
despite his new diverse surroundings his
race was still going to be a roadblock
he was partially excluded from his
college music department because of his
skin color as he revealed to People
magazine they wouldn't let me go on the
stage but they would let me behind the
curtain because there weren't any
African-Americans in the production so I
would sing in the back and I would just
sing the parts they needed me for in
2004 Jamie Fox's grandmother Estelle
Marie T passed away at her home in
Terrell Texas all of her grandson's
memories of of her raising him
overwhelmed him in the wake of her death
as he recalled to GQ I remember those
hands wiping tears from my face those
hands have me stuck at the casket I was
stuck I couldn't move Fox shared a
genuine authentic bond with his
grandmother that he doesn't have with
too many other people as he put it if
you could go to heaven right now and say
where is Estelle tally do that interview
because that's who knows me nobody else
while Fox was really shaken up at the
time in the years since he's looked back
at his experiences with his grandma
mother with nothing but love in 2019 he
celebrated her birthday on Instagram
with an old picture and a caption that
read my rock miss you always act like
you got some sense of what she would
tell me all the time while his
grandmother's death was heartbreaking a
glimmer of hope came out of it for Fox
as his father actually showed up at her
funeral after years of absence he was
tentatively testing the waters to rejoin
the family as Fox recalled to GQ his dad
asked him are you my son are you not my
my son I want to reconcile but I'm
scared Fox then opened his arms and told
his father you don't have to be scared
it is what it is alas after the funeral
his father disappeared yet again still
he remains hopeful a decade after the
funeral Fox told the Sunday Times in
2014 that the door remains open for his
father partly in hopes of settling some
of the questions that have plagued him
for years like what happened where were
you were you stricken with something
could you not make it well Fox's
biological dad was never around he was
able to find the consistent father
figure in the form of his mother's
second ex-husband George Dixon as Fox
recall to GQ my stepfather's into sports
when I was running track I'd always be
looking for my stepfather sometimes I'd
stand outside the fence and say come on
man and I'd make it I'd make the high
jump but in a tragic turn of events that
seems almost too cruel to be true Fox
almost lost his stepfather as well Dixon
was sentenced to 7 years of prison on a
drug charge which was was particularly
hard on Fox he felt like this man whom
he' admired so much had failed him
though he wasn't going to just kick him
to the curb so when he got out of prison
Fox extended an invitation as he
recalled I said you were going to live
with me I got his parole changed I said
I will save your life because your kids
are something special their father
taught me everything taught me how to
throw football of basketball T me how to
play
tennis his stepfather isn't the only
family member that Jamie Fox has taken
in and forgiven he revealed during a
2020 appearance on The Graham Norton
Show his relationship with his mother
had improved to the point that there had
been living together since 2008 Fox was
thankful to have his mom back in his
life but he also admitted that it wasn't
an immediate adjustment to whome mothers
Sun bonding the road to reconciliation
can be Rocky and there was a lot of his
childhood that he still needed to
process as he explained to the Sunday
Times in 2014 we're trying to learn
about each other you realize certain
things that you miss when you were
growing up like oh I do that because of
that Jamie Fox has been open about his
struggle with substance abuse and its
effect on his overall health this has
included drug induced mental breaks that
were bad enough that his family had to
intervene as he recalled in an interview
with hip Hollywood when that was
happening I was lucky enough to have
people like my sister like my family say
yo you can't go out right now because
you're talking crazy in 2005 Fox was
partying hard after being nominated for
an Academy Award for Ray then one week
before the Oscars he got a call from
Oprah Winfrey who stepped in to set him
straight she says all of this Gallivan
and all this kind of that's not what you
want to do whenn Frey put together an
informal intervention that helped Fox
realize that he needed to take a step
back from his Reckless lifestyle you
know sometimes in Oscars the characters
that that they award sometimes they're a
little fractured this is bigger than you
yeah it's way bigger on more than one
occasion Jamie Fox has ruffled a few
feathers with tasteless comments and
controversial Behavior for example
during a 2009 episode of his radio show
the fox hall he said about Miley Cyrus
who was 17 at the time make a sex tape
and grow up get some crack in your pipe
catch chyia on a bicycle sea then in
2015 Fox introduced Caitlyn Jenner at
the ihart Radio Music Awards which was
around the time that rumors had started
to leak about her gender transition Fox
commented during the ceremony he's doing
a his and her du all by himself look I'm
just busting your balls while I still
can fox has also come the fire for
defending controversial rappers like
Kanye West and Chris Brown as well as
mocking deaf people and exhibiting cruel
behavior on sets he's also been accused
of sexual assault a claim that he has
denied Jamie Fox was always close with
his sister DeAndre Dixon she had Down
syndrome and he often served as her
caretaker when people asked him if she
was too much of a burden he would
emphatically say no as he told GQ in
2004 if I can't take care of my sister
who has Down syndrome what will people
think of me sitting up in Mr Chow
drinking Dom perion and doing interviews
with GQ so no we won't have any of that
in 2020 Fox took to Instagram to share
the tragic news of Dixon's passing he
posted several photos of the two of them
together along with a caption that read
in part my heart is shattered into a
million pieces my beautiful loving
sister Deandra has transitioned I say
transitioned because she will always be
alive anyone who knew my sis knew that
she was a bright light what have you
learned from
learn how to live for many years Jamie
Fox's daughter Karin Fox experienced
debilitating pain and nausea during her
menstrual cycle she thought this was
normal as several doctors brushed off
her concerns as she explained to today
there's a lot of medical gaslighting
that goes into this journey I think
women of color especially are often
silenced or not believed when they come
in with symptoms Kim was eventually
diagnosed with stage four
endometriosis a condition in which
abnormal tissue grows out inside the
uterus causing extreme discomfort she
even had to undergo surgery in 2018
because the pain was so debilitating she
then became an ambassador for the
endometriosis Foundation of America as
well as an executive producer of below
the belt a documentary raising awareness
about the condition after the release of
the film her dad took to Instagram to
applaud his daughter for PowerWing
through such a severe struggle and
making something positive out of it as
he wrote so proud of my daughter please
check it out below the belt you will be
blown away by the Courage the women
possess in this film things took a very
scary turn for Jamie Fox on April 12th
2023 Karen Fox posted on social media
that her father had suffered a medical
complication though she didn't provide
any further explanation A source told
CNN that Jamie was hospitalized in
Georgia news that was met with an
outpouring of concern from friends and
fans for weeks the public was in the
dark about Fox's condition but finally
on May 12th he reassured everyone that
that he was still alive and kicking and
also to say that he was very touched by
everyone's well wishes as he wrote on
his Instagram story appreciate all the
love feeling blessed see you all soon
later that year Fox returned to
Instagram with a video to explain why
things were kept Under Wraps as he
admitted I just didn't want you to see
me like that with tubes running out of
me and trying to figure out if I was
going to make it through FOX also
cleared up some of the rumors by saying
that it wasn't as bad as some people
were speculating although it was still
pretty harrowing as he elaborated some
people said I was blind said I was
paralyzed I'm not paralyzed but I went
to hell and back if you or anyone you
know is struggling with addiction issues
help is available visit the Substance
Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration website or contact samire
National helpline that's 1800 662 help